he's still young but you've seen some
things
so uh let me ask you to put on your wise
Sage hat and uh give advice to young
people
whether they're fascinated by technology
or fascinated by fighter jets
whether they're fascinated by sort of uh
engineering or the way the stars look at
night what advice would you give them
how to have a career they can be proud
of or how to have a life they can be
proud of
I'd suggest that they don't fear looking
foolish
I spent a large portion of my life
uh considering the laughter or the the
comments that my statements as uh
indication that I shouldn't pursue that
and so you know I didn't I kind of woke
up to that fact a bit later but I would
encourage you know I would advise that
that people you know trust in themselves
and Trust in the things that they care
about it doesn't matter if they're good
at it all that matters is that they find
something that they can apply love and
care to and they will grow better at it
and they'll most likely make the world
better because of it and don't be afraid
to look stupid don't be afraid to look
stupid
uh yeah that's one of the things that I
think as you get older you're expected
to be
to have it all figured out and so you
are afraid to take on new things
but I think as long as you're always
okay looking stupid and having a
beginner's mind you can you can get
really really far even later on in life
so this isn't just advice for young
people this is really advice for uh for
everybody